being the black friend first of all let
me define what this means
so within again we're talking generally
American society but I think this gets a
little global for black people who are
in environments of mostly white people
maybe or mostly non black people but I
think especially white people we could
be talking about school about the
workplace about some sort of organized
activity like sports you have a special
role to play and we've understood in
society that black is kind of cool black
got us jazz and hip-hop and all kinds of
sports accolades and entertainment and
that's well I'm good and why people kind
of often feel better feel like it
acknowledges them as open-minded people
as progressive people to say it's really
cool I've got this black friend and
therefore I'm not racist therefore I'm
more plugged in therefore I know it's
him what is less celebrated or
understood is what the black friend can
do and has done historically for the
black community and we think often of
great civil rights leaders we think of
people who marched in the streets and
sacrifice we rarely think of the quiet
diplomatic efforts of the black friend
who was friends with white people who
answered their questions who prevented
racial conflagrations maybe even riots
by simply saying no white friend you
can't say the n-word no white friend
please don't touch my hair
no white friend not every black person
has an opinion of Barack Obama and so by
defusing potentially inflammatory
situations quietly diplomatically with a
smile and through conversation black
people in this country have benefited
greatly sorry just really right now I
like to take a moment of silence to the
unsung heroes to the black friends
who've made America better
okay I think we all feel a little better
now now I understand add that to our
history lessons the black friend